polisher handguns and flex your grenade  throwing arm the latest fall fantasy 15  DLC episode Prompto is out much like the  episode Gladius dlc this add-on not only  spotlights its title character but also  delivers a host of gameplay deviations  that you won't find in the main game  that includes a considerable amount of  third-person shooting and a snowmobile  component where you can explore a snowy  open-world and take on optional missions  this video highlights features from our  first hour of play unless you have the  season pass the DLC is 5 dollars and  you'll need the full game to play this  DLC if you enjoyed this clip give us a  like subscribe to our YouTube channel  and while you're there you can check out  a whole summers worth of final fantasy  videos including final fantasy xiv storm  blood and final fantasy 12 the zodiac  age thanks for watching  [Music]  catch you later RNA